[Musique]
ce téléphone ici pèse 70 kg alors là
vous dites sur cet homme nous ment soit
il est extrêmement costaud mais en
réalité ce téléphone a nécessité
l'exploitation de 70 kg de ressources
naturelles pour sa fabrication
alors qu'en fait il pèse à peu près 150
grammes alors second
s'explique par les grandes quantités de
minerai qu'il faut exploiter et dont on
extrait les métaux et les métaux rares
pour sa fabrication métaux rares est
rare qu'elle distinction bien les
terrasses à une définition exacte il
s'agit de 17 éléments du tableau
périodique 17 mai droit ce sont ceux qui
sont encadrés en bleu ici sur cette
image
les métaux rares quant à eux intègrent
les terreur et d'autres métaux dont la
rareté et la criticité dépend en fait de
la conjoncture économique
rave mais sont ils si rare que ça en
fait non il s'agit d'un abus de langage
puisqu'on le trouve à peu près partout
sur la croûte terrestre
on les appelle rare car on ne trouve pas
à l'état natif comme l'or ou le cuivre
on y trouvent disséminées en différents
minerais ils sont associés à des métaux
qui sont abondants comme le faire ou
l'aluminium donc leur concentration est
généralement moindre dans la couche
terrestre
d'ailleurs on en produit peut
relativement peu ses 130 mille tonnes
par an pour ses 17 éléments contre 2
milliards de tonnes rien que pour le
faire alors à quoi nous servent tous ces
métaux rares dans les trous dans des
applications aussi diverses et variées
que les éoliennes les téléphones
portables les véhicules électriques
les billets de banque les scanners
médicaux les réseaux télécommunications
optiques dans des normes dans une grande
diversité de domaines et ce sont les
vedettes de notre transition énergétique
et numérique
c'est génial parce que grâce à eux on va
pouvoir basculer massivement sur les
énergies renouvelables nous affranchir
des énergies fossiles qui mettent des
gaz à effet de serre à grands coups de
parcs d'éoliennes de faire nos panneaux
solaires et avec un petit peu numérique
pour augmenter notre effet cassé notre
efficacité énergétique
on va pouvoir mener notre croissance
verte tant attendu ça va être génial on
aimerait tous que ça se passe comme ça
mais en réalité il ya deux problèmes du
point de vue des ressources
le premier s'est grandement basculant
massivement sur les énergies
renouvelables
on a tendance à penser que on n'a plus
besoin de ressources
effectivement on émet plus de gaz à
effet serre soit d
gaz à effet de serre de l'or lors de la
fabrication la production d'électricité
on a besoin de beaucoup de ressources
par exemple la capacité de production
équivalente une éolienne fans insisté
quinze fois plus de béton les 90 fois
plus d'aluminium qu'une centrale
thermique par exemple
le deuxième problème c'est que dans
cette transition numérique on a tendance
à penser que tout devient immatériel or
il n'ya rien plus matérielles que des
data center qui stocke nous donner que
des câbles sous-marins que des
téléphones portables par exemple
alors comment elles sont nées on en est
arrivé là
une dix huitième siècle les
minéralogistes découvre la première
terreur mais c'est pas très intéressant
parce qu'on leur trouve aucune
application industrielle et aux gains
d'argent à se faire
c'est dans les années 1960-1970 qu'on
leur trouve des applications
technologiques et leur production va
commencer à croître
donc on retrouve à cet endroit là il
voit qu'à partir de cet endroit jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ce qui est la croissance la
plus forte
ce sont des rares ici et là la biennale
information importante c'est que la
population mondiale
elle croit comme ça la production terral
crois beaucoup plus c'est à dire
qu'individuellement aussi on a des
consommations qui augmente tout se passe
plutôt bien d'un qu'à partir des années
70 jusque dans les années 1980 les pays
dits industrialisés extraits et purifie
ces métaux rares mais dans les années
1980 l'opinion publique se saisit des
problèmes environnementaux et réalise
que cette activité va polluer c'est pas
vraiment souhaitable
s'ensuivent des normes environnementales
qui vont s'avérer particulièrement
strictes et faire que cette activité
n'est plus ce n'est plus rentable pour
ce faire au respect des normes
environnementales au même moment de
l'autre côté du monde en chine le pays
s'ouvre au monde et d'un jogging veut
faire du pays l'usiné du monde
il veut capitaliser sur les grandes
ressources en matières premières qu'il
possède c'est ce qui est ce qu'il va
dire aux entreprises qui n'en talent
c'est venait délocaliser chez nous on a
une main d'oeuvre qui est pas cher et
puis on vous embêtera absolument pas
avec
impacts environnementaux ou des impacts
sanitaires venez chez nous ce qui va se
passer c'est que ça va conduire à la
fermeture de la plus grosse mine
d'extraction de métaux rares à l'époque
qui m'a hanté une passe aux états unis
et ça va conduire aussi la
délocalisation des activités drones
poulain en place d une aveo leasing qui
était basé à la rochelle et qui purifier
50% du marché mondial des terreurs 50%
et à cause de ces normes
environnementales on va devoir
délocaliser en chine la chine petit à
petit va réussir a trusté toutes les
étapes de valeur des terrains elle va
commencer par extraire purifier puis
faire des mid est composé des composants
et puis jusqu'aux produits finis
toujours avec cette même stratégie
et puis en s'appropriant les
technologies une fois que les
entreprises est arrivé chez elle et bâle
s'approprier technologie faisait à leur
place alors la chine n'a pas été le seul
seul à faire ça et d'autres pays ont
aussi décidé de sacrifier leur
environnement à images du kazakhstan la
république démocratique du congo
donc ça des impacts écologiques qui sont
absolument désastreux on rejette
énormément de de métaux lourds toutes
les zones autour en fait des mines sont
contaminés ici c'est les rejets toxiques
de la ville de baotou qui se trouve en
chine et dans cette mine rien que dans
cette mine ont produit 75 % des tares
dans le monde et donc vous pouvez
imaginer qu autour de ça tout les zones
agricoles sont contaminés on a une
multiplication des maladies
cardiovasculaires et puis on a besoin
d'énormément et d'énergie en fait il
faut pouvoir concasser les minerais
il faut boire feindre le métal les
transporter il faut de grandes quantités
d'eau il faut 200 mille litres d'eau
deux cent mille litres d'eau pour
purifier une seule une seule tonne de
terreur et puis on a aussi des problèmes
éthiques c'est à dire qu'on estime en
république démocratique du congo qui lie
à 40 mille enfants mineurs qui
travaillent dans les mines de combattre
donc s'il n'est absolument pas
souhaitable mais tout le monde s'en
c'est en fait c'était à peu près
accommodé de cette situation ce que les
les producteurs ont sacrifié leur
environnement ils trouvent le retour
économique les pays occidentaux barabash
une croissance verte où tout le monde il
est tout beau il est propre
ces métaux sont aussi particulièrement
stratégique
on a une demande qui est croissante une
production assez faible et puis des
monopoles qui sont de plus en plus
croissant d'une complexité des relations
qui est assez spécifique vous donner un
exemple en septembre 2010 un chalutier
chinois s'aventure dans les eaux
japonaises le japon arraisonnent le
bateau et puis la chine demande sa
libération
sylvia sass essai de la chine en guise
de représailles va interrompre de
manière nette les exportations de terres
rares vers le japon et un peu plus tard
la chine va lever cette sanction la csa
rendu compte qu'elle ne pouvait plus
rien acheter aux japonais ne peut plus
acheter des équipements électroniques
n'est pas simplement parce que le japon
avait fait aussi un arbre en embargo
parce que le japon n'allait plus
suffisamment de terreur fabriquée les
équipements électroniques puis les
revendre aux chinois donc ça ça montre à
quel point les métaux sont stratégiques
ils sont aussi stratégique parce qu'ils
touchent le domaine de la défense les
armées en des technologiques qui ont
sont très gourmandes ce soit pour la
balistique ou bien l'électronique dans
l'est dans les avions
alors comment font les états pour
sécuriser leurs approvisionnements
ce café
la chine pendant un long moment depuis
le 7ème siècle c'est pratique et la
diplomatie du panda la diplomatie du
panda cela consiste à offrir un panda à
des états avec lesquels elle voulait
entamer des relations diplomatiques et
on peut croire que c'est bien fonctionné
parce qu'un panda c'est quand même super
mignon depuis l arrêté et est passé sur
des mesures un petit peu plus
conséquente en investissement en
investissant massivement dans les
transports en afrique pour conforter
leur route de la soie moderne et
sécuriser leurs approvisionnements en
matières matières premières lignes
européennes l'échelle de ces états la
commission européenne va publier tous
les trois ans un rapport avec les
matières critique donc qui sont évalués
selon le risque sur l'approvisionnement
et l'importance économique
il ya plein d'autres méthodes par
exemple celle de jouer avec le droit
maritime
les états vont étendre leur domaine
maritime pour pouvoir sécuriser des
endroits où il peut y avoir
potentiellement des gisements
d'hydrocarbures
la france en 2015 a étendu son
territoire maritime de 280 mille
kilomètres carrés
c'est à peu près la surface de
l'hexagone en fait et en jouant avec les
limites du plateau continental ils ont
pu s'octroyer une surface le qui se
tient à tours en fait les îles kerguelen
les îles de nouvelle calédonie et c est
donc ça leur donne là ça donne la france
la priorité de l'exploitation des sols
des ressources des sols et des sous-sols
alors comment est ce que nous en tant
que citoyen on peut agir comme en fait
échelle bien la première des solutions
c'est d'en prendre conscience et d'en
être
c'est de sa forme et d'être alerté de
ces problèmes c'est savoir que par
exemple dans une voiture électrique a
besoin de 1,2 à 3,5 kg de terreur que
dans une éolienne il en faut à peu près
de 200 une fois qu'on en est conscient
c'est passé à l'étape 2 c'est la
sobriété consommation c'est à dire
limiter sa consommation assez stricts
besoins et joue la corde
c'est pas très évident surtout si on
parle de l'obsolescence perçue par le
consommateur
là je vous parle pas de l'obsolescence
programmée je vous parle de
l'obsolescence culturel l'obsolescence
culturel c'est celle qui fait que marc
au téléphone je lui ai acheté il ya
trois ans il fonctionne encore bien mais
quand même il vachement un gars par
rapport à ce qui sort ces années là ils
ont une meilleure performance de la
batterie
la résolution de l'appareil photo et qui
aime bien mieux j'ai quand même envie
d'acheter la dr technologies et tout ça
ça pour conséquence qu'on en moyenne on
change tous les deux un téléphone
portable et sur ses téléphones 88% de
fonctionne encore et donc en france
rien qu'en france on estime à 30
millions de téléphones portables qui
danse dans nos tiroirs et qui sont même
pas exploité
von perfall c'est une société
hollandaise qui a pour ambition de
s'approvisionner de manière éthique en
matière première pour concevoir leur
téléphone portable et d'augmenter la
longévité ses téléphones en les rendant
modulaire c'est à dire que les
composants lorsqu'ils vont devenir
lorsqu'ils vont tomber en panne mis hors
d'usagé
on va pouvoir les remplacer ou de vous
remplacer le téléphone dans sa totalité
le but c'est d'avoir des téléphones qui
dura vie et on se rend compte que on
apprend récemment que faire phone va
lancer le faire fauntroy
ça montre à quel point des entreprises
comme ça sont six captifs d'un progrès
technologiques qui est recherché par les
consommateurs le sol et sans ce
programme et elle évidemment lutter
contre ces deux solutions ce programme
et fait partie d'une des solutions qu'on
a et d'ailleurs elle est punie depuis
2015 par la loi est passible de deux ans
d'emprisonnement et 300 mille euros
damende mes problèmes de ça c'est que
c'est encore très difficile à prouver
puisque il faut prouver qu'une
entreprise a délibérément réduit la
durée de vie d'un produit
donc on pourrait penser que une des
méthodes meilleure méthode soit le
recyclage le recyclage et oui parce que
si au lieu d'aller extraire de nouveaux
métaux dans les minerais on pourrait
utiliser ce qui arrivait en fin de vie
sanusi vie serait quand même quelques
problèmes
ça serait formidable au problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est toujours le
recyclage ne toujours pas rentable pour
les terreur serre qu'il vaut mieux aller
continuer à en extraire de les recycler
et aujourd'hui moins de 1% des thés
rares sont recyclés dans le monde le
site l'âge du pourtant recadré par un
cadre règlementaire via une directive de
l'union européenne depuis 2002 et qui
était révisée en 2012 et donc ils
donnent des salades des oeufs
la directive pour les déchets et
d'équipements électroniques et
électriques et qui donne des objectifs
de collecte et de recyclage
ça vous avez peut-être vu écosystèmes ce
sont des boîtes vertes qu'on voit la
sortie des caisses de supermarché dans
lesquels vous pouvez déposer vos
appareils électroménagers en fin de vie
et peut système est financé par l'époux
contribution vous savez
l'éco-contribution c'est ce qu'on paie
lorsqu'on va acheter un ordinateur à
mille euros c'est les 50 centimes
pompey supplémentaires et qui vont
financer des éco-organismes écosystèmes
pour la collecte et le recyclage de ce
qu'on peut encore recyclés sûr c'est sur
ces équipements au-delà du recyclage et
la réutilisation c'est donner une
nouvelle vie à nos appareils et ça c'est
possible dans ce qu'on appelle les
rippeurs café dans les rippeurs café aux
et des personnes
des équipements qui vont permettre de
réparer dans la mesure du possible vos
équipements en fin de vie autres ses
cheveux au téléphone portable et vous
trouverez aussi sur internet des
tutoriels comme ifixit où on vous
apprend à vous le faire vous même si
vous avez effectivement vous l'avez
compris recyclage c'est prometteur
mais là encore faut-il trouver une
méthode rentable et c'est l'objet de
recherches de plusieurs instituts de
recherche notamment le seven cnrs qui se
sont alliés pour le projet cythère le
projet cythère l'idée c'est d'utiliser
des éponges en fibre de carbone pour
séparer et puis purifier les terreur le
brgm c'est le bureau de recherche
géologique et minier lui via le projet
extrade a pour ambition de recycler les
disques durs et la corée pour le projet
need for haïti a pour ambition lui de
s'intéresser à durabilité sur plusieurs
dimensions économiques technologiques
sur la durabilité des objets connectés
et ce projet de recherche est porté par
l'université grenoble alpes depuis juin
et si on relançait le l'activité minière
en france alors ça pourrait choquer mais
c'est l'idée que certains on sait de
réouvrir les mines en france et oui
rappelez-vous dans les années 1980
lorsqu'on à délocaliser notre production
on a aussi délocaliser les impacts de
nos consommations
on s'est séparé des coûts écologiques
liés à notre consommation
et si on les faisait revenir plus tard
peut-être ça nous ferait changer d'avis
prenez les maldives par exemple leurs
habitants sont un petit peu plus
conscient de la montée des eaux
lorsqu'ils savent que d'ici cent à deux
cents ans il pourrait être ils pourront
être engloutis l'idée c'est de
rapprocher les impacts pour qu'on soit
davantage concerné et vigilants à propos
de ça et d'ailleurs la france à quelques
ressources minières à faire valoir
on estime que dans les 30 prochaines
années on va de vous
extraire autant de minerais que ce qu'a
fait l'humanité de toute son histoire
c'est à dire que pendant soixante dix
mille ans 108 milliards d'habitants se
sont succédé et en trente ans c'est à
dire en une génération 5 milliard
d'habitants on va devoir extraire autant
de minerais que tout ce monde là
ce téléphone est toujours 70 kg jusqu'où
pourront nous perdre du poids merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]